[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting uh we have had some dreams uh
dreams are good funny thing is is last
night when we spoke on the phone like we
do every night we put each other to bed
over the phone good night good night
link good night buddy uh during your my
nightly took you into bed with my voice
call uh you told me
that you had a dream that you wanted to
share with me today yeah and here we are
the future is here yes and I think that
that put a thought into my head which
was to have a dream to have a dream and
then also to remember the dream because
when I woke up
I'd had a funny dream weird dream or
whatever and just because you had told
me that you were gonna tell me about
your dream I was like you gotta do it
you gotta get up and I dictated it into
my phone you're trying to out dream me
no I'm just saying I'm trying to outdo
my dreams with your dreams I was trying
to say thank you by what uh thank you
for giving me the reason to remember my
dream because otherwise it would have
just been another dream that's lost Into
The Ether forever but I'll get a voice
memo uh I dictate that's that's a good
idea I do a lot of dictating into my
phone so I turn on the little things so
that now it dictates it wrong a lot of
the time but does it gets good enough
that you can remember it this is
actually how I Journal now oh what I
would say 40 to 60 which could be
rounded to fifty half of the time I
Journal by
I have a thought and instead of doing a
memo that I that I won't be able to
search the text and I won't be able to
organize
I begin to talk into my phone comma
and I say things like insights that I
have in life period new paragraph I will
begin doing this on a regular basis
period new paragraph unless it doesn't
go well period
so I've gotten pretty good the problem
is is anybody an earshot of this uh do
you think I care
I think you should if that's your tone
it's not a good look I don't do it at
the mall if that's what you mean I mean
even for people who love you it it
really makes this question I don't do it
in front of anybody it's like do we want
to keep loving him no this is uh because
he's doing that what is he uh what is he
trying to do an autobiography this is
exclusively honestly it happens like in
the morning when I'm
uh working out
I like to journal while I work out the
tone of voice you're using at least I
was doing that for the people Captain's
Log you have to speak very clearly so
Siri will understand what you say you
have to speak in a Midwestern Middle
America accent that a news anchor would
speak in so that Siri will understand
because that is the voice that Siri has
been
um programmed to think is the center of
the way that people talk in this
particular country using this particular
language I don't know what that says
about Siri
but it says that if I don't talk like a
Midwestern news anchor Siri will not
accurately transcribe what I say period
new paragraph sincerely comma new
paragraph Rhett McLaughlin just do an
earshot sweep before you do that
you know your shot sweep just make sure
there ain't nobody with any of your shot
and if there is you just gotta wait but
this has got me thinking of a couple of
things
I want to hear your dream though I know
but I want I want to be able to journal
and when you say Journal you're talking
about jotting down dear diary comma you
talking about like at the end of each
day I don't do that that's what I'm not
on a freak
I think it would be so good it's
therapeutic I don't do morning pages
what is this a Jeff Bezos Jenna knows
about that
the the artist's way she knows about
that okay great for y'all
um listen writing every day I don't do
that why not just record a voice memo
and then have that translated and then
you have your voice you have a recording
of yourself well there is an app I had a
dream last night there is an app and I
think me and you actually is it called
dream uh I don't know if this is built
into the new iOS I mean everybody's
talking about the new iOS
but I am years ago you and I
had a conversation had a crazy idea I
don't remember we recorded it in a voice
memo and then we were talking to someone
and they're like you should just
transcribe that to text there's an app
for that and we did it I don't remember
and I don't think it worked well
I don't want to hear what I sounded like
I don't like the sound of my own voice I
just want a journal
I do like the sound of my voice when I
talk like a Midwestern news anchor
though
I'm gonna start doing that
for myself so that's how you got your I
want you to read what the transcription
is of your dream to see what's wrong I
oh you're getting cringe no I got it's a
better it's better for me to tell you
the dream than to read the transcription
because the transcription is like a cue
for me to remember what actually I want
your dream to be told to me oh my God
you know
it's one of those dreams that it was I
was just so worked up about it I was I
was Disturbed I was I was really in my
what are you in it's not oats it's um
you're a horse I was out of my uh it was
just shook you up it shook me up yeah I
was shaken up to the point of waking up
shaking not stirred
no shaking wake
and I I woke up just enough to realize
oh he was a dream
oh wow
I think this is like
4 a.m ish it's a bad time to wake up
from a dream it's an early time
go back to sleep go back another dream
Marky Mark would be up doing pull-ups at
that time and praying and cinder blocks
he put He does a pull-up and he prays to
the Lord and he comes back down and he
comes back and he prays to the Lord he's
got an app for praying Marky Mark does
and uh I don't know if you know that so
he's so he doesn't pull up he prays he
says a couple of he also does some other
things and then he lifts the cinder
blocks but his Catholic prayer it's
scripted
uh Catholics can pray any way they want
to man what you got against Catholics
but I think that
that he probably says a few Hail Marys
yes they got some scripts when he's
doing the cinder blocks I'm just saying
Marky Mark he's up at 4am he doesn't go
back to sleep I went back to sleep and I
go back into the dream and then
I I was waking and quaking again um
scared waking up a second time
and I woke up more this time I was like
this was a dream don't get so worked up
about this
and I had that relief feeling of oh my
gosh it's a dream thank God and then
pray I lowered myself from the pull-up
bar and I went back to sleep and it
happened a third time and it's the same
dream same dream the relief is not worth
the anguish you re-entered into the same
dream for a third time and it wasn't it
was an anticipation of something
happened
so
here's what it was
you and I
were going to have a boxing match right
and it was like obviously it was some
sort of publicity start a little bit of
desperation or something we did on our
own I think we're doing it on our own
and we don't want to travel to Florida
yeah no
but here's the catch
no boxing gloves well of course this is
going to be like a street fight oh we're
going raw dog if we do it street fight
punching each other in the face and
fight to the death wait no no it wasn't
a fight to the death it was like uh it
was surreal that it was gonna happen we
wouldn't even do the little like
ultimate fighting gloves nope and that's
what I was so I was like why are we
doing it this way because it was
something that we were planning we were
both we weren't mad at each other we
were we were desperate for something
clicks I don't know eventually we'll do
it Fame I don't know
because that it is kind of a running
joke over the years once they once
people who have no business
fighting each other started fighting
each other it's like well of course we
could we could pull that lever if we've
got to and it would be probably the most
popular thing that we've done in many
years if we were to do it but let's just
say just so you know it's not happening
it's oh okay it's definitely not
happening don't talk about it happening
because I now know what it feels like to
to believe that it's happened oh you but
it didn't happen it doesn't matter that
that's the thing about dreams I don't
think you realize is that it's an
absolute
completely real simulation of reality
that involves every emotion when you say
I didn't realize evolved in it you've
involved it I'm familiar with dreams
I've read about dreams why are you
saying I'm not familiar with it
I was I know what it feels like to know
that we're gonna we're gonna
street fight and it feels horrible I
mean you should be very very scared of
it it feels well just because of your
reach uh bro I would rip you apart I
mean you might get a couple of shots in
but as soon as I started Landing stuff
it would be ugly or so fast now that
we're gonna do it I'm not saying we're
going to do it that's ever going to do
it I'm just saying I would rip you apart
man all I have to do and I was like I
would mow you down it wasn't the morning
it was like it was weeks off in the
calendar and I had weeks to just be in
English about this thing
but hey I would I was thinking about
like my guard and I was like talking to
people about it yeah right through it I
was talking to me about it and I was
like you know what if I just get in some
if I get in a good one early he he you
know he he he just bleed like a pig and
cried like a baby if you hit me in the
nose I would start bleeding but I would
punch you out before I bled to death you
have no technique
I did the Billy Blanks thing for my wife
like 10 years ago you know how I commit
to things man
I would get a trainer I'm not doing it
we're not doing it okay
so stop asking for it the thing is is
that the time move your fist to the end
of your arm I could be I could be
buzzing all around you man mythical
beasts this is you know and I think this
is a great thing about this wonderful
community of fans that we have built is
they don't want to see us fight man sure
there's some there's some there's some
but they they actually the idea that we
would get into a fist fight with each
other they're like no no no no no so
brings him his mother Angels brings me
yeah I I actually think that it's a
horrible I don't even want to see it I
don't want to do it here's the thing
let's not do it in the process of nearly
murdering you I would hurt myself badly
I'm just gonna go ahead and tell you
that by the end of this thing we both be
in a hospital all I got to do you would
be in the hospital no you'd be in the
hospital for me hitting you one I would
be in the hospital from me hitting you
because I'm gonna throw something out so
my neck's gonna go my back but I'm gonna
get some shots in my
you know what this was an opportunity
for you to empathize here was the thing
this was an opportunity for you to say
man yeah you really got worked up over
yeah I'm sorry I was basically saying
that I was afraid of it yeah yeah I
would have to lean into that I was
saying focus on this I was like I
understand what you were saying I had a
lot of empathy because you know how bad
it would be for you and I'm and I
understand that that is the truth and so
I'm feeling for you on behalf of what
you would feel if you had to fight me
I'm actually this is me caring about you
you know so I'm sorry man I'm sorry you
had that triple dream
uh about me almost kicking your ass the
waiting is the hardest part I bet you us
fighting wouldn't be nearly as bad as me
dreaming about it
you know what let's do it
um let's do it
oh you know I don't wanna yeah the last
thing I want to do is ever punch anybody
in I've never punched anybody in the
face I punched two people named John in
the stomach
once in defense of you thank you uh and
I've had two one punch fights in my life
so I'll do body shots as well so you get
looking out for that it's amazing how
real dreams can be and it's just all up
here man well it just kind of makes you
question you know
question what what is real you know
right if a dream can be that real and
it's all here
then there's so much other stuff that's
probably not as real as I think it is
I don't know if you're drawing the right
conclusion there but I'll let you rest
wrestle with that okay well then my
conclusion is I need to up my anxiety
medication no no no I mean that's
between you and your and your doctor a
coach yeah it's like your life coach
yeah he's he's giving me that one PhD
see that I uh seen that see that
Oh Billy Blanks right there man
the one thing I did notice you trying to
attend me the one thing I didn't notice
about Billy Blanks is his face is a
little messed up Billy Blanks is he's a
he's a he's like a fitness guy I think
it's because he got punched in the face
all I I know everything I need to know
about the way you think about boxing I
don't even think about boxing you think
about Billy Blanks I don't want to learn
anything from a guy you think about
Facebook marred up from getting hit I
want a pristine face someone who's who's
been through it and it's still pristine
it's like they're that that's who I want
to learn from because that that's what I
need I need to keep pristine
um yeah and that's why I'm not gonna
fight you because I want people to
continue to think that you're a good
looking guy because I think it helps us
get views I can't even if I break one oh
it does if I break one of your eye
sockets which I definitely would would
do
we would lose something I would lose
something you see what I'm saying that's
why I'm not going to fight you
well maybe I can straighten your nose
back uh I had a dream and I'm not as
confused about reality after the dream
but I do think it was a funny dream that
I'm going to tell you about it in a
second they can be so real
um but first
we're going to you know what we've done
we do all kinds of stuff I mean we're
always doing something new
you probably get tired of hearing about
the latest thing that we've done
uh because this is cool though but this
is a little bit different sometimes we
we make things and I'm so excited about
it I take a picture of it and I send it
to my family like my immediate family
your little thread your text thread yeah
what do you call that this is one of the
name of y'all's family textured f-a-m
fam oh all caps okay
I don't know what it stands for but it's
all caps uh ours is just D didn't ask
but I actually I asked you so I could
say what mine is um
Sean and Barbara's people
that's long yeah
um okay so this is the last quarterly
item of the year for the mythical
Society remember you got to be a third
degree member of the mythical Society in
order to get these items and this is we
have partnered with
guess who the official uh all right give
me just give me a minute the official
guess who what just give me a minute
uh
Milton Bradley um no I think it's
actually is a Hasbro who makes it Hasbro
it's Hasbro uh yeah guess who the game
you know the game where you've got like
faces and you're trying to memorize them
and you're going to guess the other
person yeah we there's a strategy in
world dominical
world domination there is a mythical
Guess Who game that has every character
that you can think of in the mythical
universe and then some that you've
forgotten about I mean it goes super
super deep
um so all your favorite crew and
characters there's an add-on pack that
goes even deeper
join third degree monthly well you hold
on you don't have to the add-on pack
comes with it yeah yeah it's all it's
all it's all part of it it comes with
that we're not nickel and diming you uh
well yeah because all you gotta do is be
a third degree member join third degree
monthly by Halloween
okay October 31st 20 third degree
monthly by Halloween if you want to get
this thing it's pretty pretty awesome
and listen tell me well uh before I tell
you my dream I want to do the thing that
we keep forgetting to do which is rating
review we want you if you enjoy the
podcast to rate and review wherever you
enjoy it because it helps
ear biscuits is brought to you by better
help if you're anything like me then
there are times where you know exactly
the change that you need to make the
thing that you want to do the thing that
you know would be good for you but there
are just other parts of your brain that
get in the way of you making that change
and those can be difficult things to
sort through well therapy can help you
figure out what's holding you back so
you can work for yourself instead of
against yourself you know we are huge
advocates for therapy and we want it to
be as accessible as possible to anyone
anywhere at any time if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try it's entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge make
your brain your friend with better help
visit betterhelp.com ear today to get 10
sent off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com ear earbiscus
is supported by chime I remember when I
learned what a credit score was it was
when I found out that I had an
incredibly low one because of what we
had done to the apartment that we lived
in in college which for some reason your
name wasn't on the lease so you didn't
suffer in the way that I did well I knew
about a credit score before you did so I
spent quite a lot of time trying to
build mine back up you may think a
credit score is no big deal but if
you're dealing with a low credit score
or no credit score at all that could be
a problem for your future financial
goals that's why millions of people
swear by Chimes secured credit Builder
Visa credit card credit Builder is just
a better way to build credit you build
your credit score safely with everyday
purchases and on-time payments no annual
fees interest or credit check to apply
you can use it everywhere Visa credit
cards are accepted and you're building
credit using your own money and with a
chime checking account you can get paid
up to 2 days earlier with a qualifying
direct deposit plus you can overdraft up
to 200 without fees with spot me when
you set up that qualifying direct
deposit and sign up for spot me chime
will spot you up to your limit when you
make a purchase that exceeds your
balance chime also has access to over
sixty thousand fee-free ATMs found
easily with the chime app that's more
than the top three National Banks
combined your credit's a big deal so
build yours up with chime just open up a
chime checking account with a 200
qualified direct deposit to get started
get started at chime.com ear that's
chime.com ear the time credit Builder
Visa credit card is issued by stride
Bank n a member FDIC chime checking
account and 200 qualifying direct
deposit required to apply out of network
ATM withdrawal fees May apply on-time
payment history may have a positive
impact on your credit score late payment
May negatively impact your credit score
results May Vary
[Music]
dream
they can be surreal I can't remember the
uh
I can't remember the preceding events I
don't know what was happening but the
part that I remember is Jesse and I are
on a bus traveling to an event but not
like Yellowstone
[Music]
geyser like cross-country bus like oh
city bus to get to something and
everybody on the bus is going to the
same place you know like sometimes if
you have to go to Yellowstone geyser you
mean Greyhound no no I'm talking about
like if you're in Yellowstone and you're
going to see a guy that's a shuttle bus
that's like a shuttle bus okay I'm
saying they don't go across the country
this this is the kind of but no this is
not across the country this is the kind
of thing where like remember that year
that we went to some award show and we
had to like Park and then get on a bus
and everybody was going to the same
place in these buses it was that kind of
thing yeah like a parking lot then bus
to an event
well it does sound like a Yellowstone
bus a shuttle bus uh no but it was a
full-size bus that's what I'm that's
what I'm saying but it was everyone on
the bus was going to the same event it
wasn't like a city bus gotcha
even though I did say city bus earlier
what I meant was a bus that was in the
city
that was more detail than needed to have
it
all I remember is you might need a good
punch to the face we were on stairs that
were very very steep it was the kind of
stairs that if you find stairs outside
that go like 20 stairs and then there's
like a landing and then 20 stairs and
then a landing and then 20 stairs and a
landing like you see in some hilly
cities yeah that's that's OSHA
requirement you know that's just pure
safety it's because if you start rolling
down the hill you gotta you gotta stop
that's why they call it a landing this
woman was driving the bus and she was
barreling down the stairs
and we were all really really scared but
she was saying
I do this all the time shortcut she's
like I'm actually very good at it
and we were like this is crazy this
woman is driving this bus down these
stairs and it feels out of control I
mean it was like
it was smoother than you would think
when we were on the stairs and then it
was jarring on The Landings something
about there's a number of wheels in the
size it would like kind of get on the
stairs and then boom and then you know
wow and then we get to the bottom and
she has an idea to do this like thing
where she skids the bus right up to the
entrance of the event damn and it does
it and then it gets right to the side
and then it falls on its side
gently yeah like I almost didn't yeah
you know what I mean which side were you
on the side the low side not good but I
don't remember people getting on top of
me I just remember like oh now we're
outside of the bus like the it was you
know how you'll skip a little bit of
time in a dream or maybe skip a little
bit of time in my memory while I was
dictating this then we walk into the
event and it is one of those can I ask
you about this part before we move on
sure
how scared were you because my point is
nearly as scared as you were getting
your ass thinking about that's not
that's not how I thought about it okay
okay I was afraid for both of us okay
all right but it was I don't know if I
said it was so real you have it's and it
was I was so worked up that I kept
waking up yet you're in like
you're in like a scene from a Marvel
movie and and you're just like oh yeah
I'm gonna you know it's like you weren't
you didn't believe it you didn't even
believe your own dream
like you didn't experience the emotion
well I think the thing that you're
talking about is you woke up at a very
dire point in your dream and we're in
the middle of like an emotional response
I'm telling you about the middle of my
dream I haven't woken up yet all right
that's fair
uh India exciting things happen in
dreamslink it's one of the wonders of
the human mind that's scary as hell so
we we get out of the the side turn bus
and we go into this event and this is
the kind of thing
um it's like one of those events where
there's like sponsors there like people
have like oh there's this display for
this product that is being sold here
because oh that must be one of the
sponsors of this Gala or whatever okay
it was I don't know
I don't know what the nature of the
event was I cannot remember how I was
dressed you don't remember what the what
the placard said or like I remember this
one particular display okay I walk in
and I see this display and it is a
branded display that kind of looks like
um it's three TV screens kind of in a
wave of water kind of made like out of
some material
and it is an ad
like a physical standing ad for some
sort of aquatic product aquatic product
aquatic product new paragraph aquatic
product aquatic product
um
and like fins like fins or something
okay and then I look on the screen and
there's people swimming on the screen
demonstrating this product
and then I look and I see this man
swimming out of like a hole in a wall on
the screen
and it's me
[Laughter]
dude it's me with the Aquatic product so
I mean you got main character syndrome
dude and no and I was immediately like
what is ha what and I said oh no this is
when Jesse and I did that thing like we
went scuba diving or snorkeling in some
place and I signed a waiver I told you
not to be signing those waivers I signed
the waiver and in the waiver apparently
was giving permission for them to use my
likeness to sell their product okay and
the first thing I thought was flanning
is going to be mad at me
I was like oh no these are our business
our business guy here at mythical he's
like oh you know I shouldn't shouldn't
have done this I shouldn't have done
this I gotta read the waiver dude they
saw you waver they were like dude we got
like the rip off Jason Momoa we're gonna
put him in the aqua
Aquaman but that's not all that happened
because again Jesse was also there and
she signed the waiver as well and so I
look at the a hole yes knowing that my
wife is about to come out of that hole
and sure enough here she comes swimming
out of this hole on the screen okay and
for some reason she comes I guess
because she needed to like she was
coming out of the hole and she like did
something with her hands like put her
hands this is the dumbest thing that
I've ever heard she puts her hands like
this or her elbows were like the first
thing to come out but they were kind of
near her chest and it created an optical
illusion that she was bare chested good
like she was coming tits out into this
display she was doing the old elbow
titty yeah and like man those are some
bony tickets and I was and I was like oh
my gosh
that I know this this is not the way it
happened but the way that this video is
reproduced it looks like my wife who was
standing right next to me we just got
off the bus stairs that's an
understatement uh my wife is topless on
this ad and I I didn't even agree I
didn't think I agreed to this and I saw
I was in a little bit of a panic and I
woke up there you go see but then I
became a rational awaked person and said
to myself that was only a dream
I did that too and then I got happy
because I was like oh Elaine told me
about his dreams I did that I'm gonna
remember this dream and then I turned
over
to my phone and I said
dream colon
going to some event woman driving us in
a bus downstairs as she talks about how
good she is it is at it
in the mood to the bottom
see this is where it doesn't understand
what I said in the mood to the bottom
and the bus falls on its side and then
we walk into this event and there is
like three TVs together in this display
and it's me swimming but it's for some
reason for some product like some fins I
know I asked for this but because
something before I signed a waiver which
let them use my likeness and Jesse was
there and we're like swimming out of
these like holes get to the titty Park a
lot and the way that it's framed Like
Jesse comes out and she's got her elbows
pulled up and it looks like her boobs so
it looks like she's a topless woman in
the middle of this event that we just
walked into
nice
so what does that say about me
I'm I'm never signing another waiver I'm
less interested in what it says about
you and more about this idea I mean it's
like isn't this like this could be the
next planking it's it's a very like
third grade it's a very middle school
boy makes boobs with elbows kind of
thing it's kind of like when people turn
it's kind of thing thighs into what did
they turn they turn hot dogs into legs
or legs hot dogs in the legs very
different thing this is turning elbows
into boobies which is a middle school
playground thing uh very common in some
parts how what do you like this uh so
like if they're bare no no no what you
do is you have a shirt that's stretchy
it's usually a t-shirt you bring your
arms into your shirt okay you make elbow
boobs L boobs it for sure is what a lot
of people say but I but it's better to
do it without oh goodness yeah see that
is a middle school boy thing it's pretty
cool uh get let's get a profile
I mean look at that
yeah so that's what my wife was doing
while swimming believe it or not while
swimming out of a hole Bob Wills I think
so
Bob Wills it
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
it's fun in it
it was only just a dream
summer some are close some Far okay I
had something else I wanted to talk
about
um
I had the distinct privilege and honor
of being present at the most recent
appearance of one Elkhound snuggle baby
oh you're talking about The Comeback
Special uh-huh and I have I have uh I
have a little bit of video that we'll
put in here at some point oh I I I did
want to talk about this oh you want to
talk about it well yeah I want to talk
about it too I don't know I just I I
wanted to hear
your thoughts about this because I let
me set up the background here okay
um our friend Ward boy what a great guy
every year for Ward's birthday what he
does is he invites his friends over to
his house for a jam session sing-along
party you did he did it two years in a
row
I was like well this is an annual thing
now and so he likes to put his
middle-aged friends on the spot and say
bring some songs that we can sing print
out chords and lyrics
collate multiple copies and so you can
hand them out everybody and everybody
brings an instrument that they can play
or think they can but not laminated
um we don't laminate because that's
wasteful one year somebody brought a
trumpet
or was it a saxophone it was it was uh
it was something it was a band
instrument and it was out of place but I
think it was his sister so nobody said
anything oh I loved it it was cool it
was fun because like you know anything
goes it was it was a it was a group
small enough to make it just awkward
enough for everybody had to participate
and one guy which is nice one of those
boxes one of those percussion boxes that
you sit on and then hit yeah yeah
suspicious I really like that really I
really like it
um
but he talked to me he calls me on the
phone
no pretext either
just call straight up you know well
something must be up this is important
hey Ward what's up he's like you know my
birthday's coming up and I've decided
this year I don't want to do the
sing-along I want to do a dance party
like I want I want to dance yeah I want
all of my friends to dance
and I I started to get a little twinkle
in my eye because I I you figured you I
thought you felt like there was an
invitation you knew what was coming next
he was like you've had this dream enough
time yeah he was like would you be
willing to and I was like yes
I made up my mind I was gonna say yes
when a DJ opportunity presented itself
because I needed to get back out there
but I didn't realize to the extent that
I needed to get back out there he was
like what's your DJ name I was like L
count snuggle baby man
um parentheses around snuggle baby I
mean no DJ ahead you haven't been I just
got to say you haven't been pushing it
too hard lately it's not on water he
didn't remember I wanted to come to me
okay yeah and he did
and uh I just made my mind I wasn't
going to overthink it it's like it's
going to be an automatic yes especially
in this friendly environment I was like
this is a perfect way to get back on the
horse
then I started to think about you know
it's been quite a while since I've done
on the elk because on the you know on
the elk
I told you about my last DJ set which
was my second ever DJ set which was like
a year ago just after mythicon it was
the complete and utter Middle School
Halloween party failure yeah yeah yeah
which is completely on record you're
still at this venue you're still but you
were still recovering from that and I
it hadn't I mean it has such an impact
on me that I just I hadn't gotten back
out out there you let it get you down
and I was like you know what this is
this is it
and um
you know what I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna talk about the work I put into it
or the prep or anything I until and
until you start to criticize it and then
I'm gonna make you feel like so
let's hear about what happens if you're
gonna make fun of my DJs
if I was gonna criticize you I wouldn't
have brought it up
um you got your you got your no I want
it straight because I really do want to
know what your observations were this is
I really
am interested in this I didn't wear I
didn't wear the get up because there
wasn't enough room ceiling's too small
too short you know it was a it was a
living room so I didn't wear the antlers
you need an arena for this and if I
don't wear the antlers I'm not going to
wear the fur tunic
and if I'm not gonna wear the fur tunic
I'm not I did wear shorts
I did do that first of all and I did
have the sign I will say
um you did the right thing I believe
given given the atmosphere the setting
right to not go full get up I didn't
want to make it about me I wanted to
make it about people dancing now Ward
really wanted everybody to dance we had
many conversations about like
getting people to dance like I have
thoughts on this like that's included in
my review is it going to be on the deck
is it going to be in the living room
there was so much that went into the
prep of this thing and I knew that it
was on my shoulders it like
I to make or break his party
okay wow yeah because it was a dance
party and you were the DJ
now I understand I understand that you
made the call
to make sure that the living room became
the dance floor because originally he
was thinking maybe it would be outside
it would be the deck yeah out on the
deck uh so first of all you were
completely right about that thank you
the the living room was perfect for that
yeah good call
that was a 40-minute conversation uh
there was a moment I'll just say I'm
gonna start with
the shaky moment okay that kind of
preceded things now first of all people
show up we cleared out his whole living
room like we cleared out the couch we
cleared out all he had a whole shelving
unit got the furniture he cleared out
everything we pushed the pianos forward
the back of the piano is Where I Stood
so that that my DJ deck was on the piano
we rented PA equipment that was way too
big for this environment and we also
rented a party light
yeah
yeah now music was playing when I
arrived but you but it was it wasn't a
dance party at the time it was music is
playing you know music is playing people
getting to know each other people
catching up nerves eating drinking and
arousing
uh I knew
I was thinking about this I knew you
were thinking about it and I knew Ward
was thinking about it okay these are a
bunch of middle-aged folk uh who
don't do this there's a barrier to just
begin dancing in someone's home all
right there's there's a barrier to begin
dancing for a lot of people right
including me you know I'm not like I
love to dance but I'd hate to dance at
the same time
if that makes sense yeah once I'm doing
it I'm going for it but the barrier to
entry to begin dancing sometimes it's
like
nah
and I figured that this is common
so there have been light music playing
and I kept realizing it was a group it's
getting dark first of all I was
appreciating all the choices you were
making you know you always do a great
job good vibe you're
playlist choices has never been your DJ
weakness you know like you make great
decisions about it's really it's really
the thing where you faltered is some of
the technical
decisions and situations like that
but yeah like making sure that the
laptop continues to function that kind
of thing in front of the middle
schoolers
um but I was like okay it's dark now it
feels like this is probably when the
dance party is going to start
link comes well
El count snuggle baby comes out onto the
deck where most of the party has
gathered and basically you said it this
is how I remember it you were like okay
the dance party is about to begin
and you
so you got everybody's attention said
that and you turned around and then you
walked right into the glass of the of
the door
the dance party is about to begin yeah
it was an about face and they're like
turn two steps
and then you like sit like first of all
it was a glass it was it was screaming
it was screening it was screen because I
don't remember a bang but also no one
laughed nobody ever it wasn't like no
one no one said anything there was like
no laughing and no like oh it was just
sort of like
everyone just got a froze no one knew
what to do but then you're like oh what
and then you like grabbed the handle and
like okay here we go and you went
through this yeah when that happens yeah
you get I mean if you haven't broken
through the screen then you open the
door and you just keep going you just
got to get away mostly the majority of
people there I did not know personally
right yeah yeah yeah yeah but that was a
that was my first impression at that
point I was like okay uh this is either
great that he got that out of the way
got that out of the system or this is
like a sign of things to come and I will
find out momentarily uh what if I would
have had the antlers on it would have
been so good you would have never made
it to the door I wouldn't still be on
the deck right
it'd have been like caught you know how
you see like a you'll see a deer you
know sometimes you can come up to like
an L in the forest and get stuck and
they can get stuck yeah like and they'll
die that way sometimes they'll get
another deer's head stuck on them I've
seen that too yeah you can Tick Tock
that yeah and you know what that could
have been me man the rest of the night I
just could have been you made the right
call now and everybody everybody had
this all right everybody's gonna stay on
the deck or go all the way around
because
so you get back in you made it to the
station
and you began playing music okay and of
course this is Ward's party and Ward is
uh very enthusiastic and also very like
um
he's he's not afraid to be like come on
let's do this kind of thing right he's
gonna he's gonna encourage you
to get started dancing
yeah and it didn't take long
before
the dancing was happening
yeah and Jesse and I went out there we
were having a great time but you missed
do you remember the sound effect part oh
oh yeah because that you missed that
part because that's actually what drew
me inside right because Ward was like I
was like yeah I did my thing like
running into the thing and then I was
like oh I'm here and I started
playing my set yeah and right just when
people were wondering who is that guy
that just ran into the screen door yeah
oh come on snuggle baby oh oh oh oh oh
oh counting snuggle baby oh oh oh oh oh
Kellen snuggle baby yeah I still had
those yeah sound effects which again but
the but I think was a good call after
the first song and
one person one couple two couples in
Ward were out there
um I might have played a second song
then I was like you know what this isn't
working this is this is the point where
it doesn't happen it's not a dance party
and so I stopped the music entirely and
I only played
L count snuggle baby because I was like
I had to get their attention something I
think that was a good call
because I was I was a bit strange I was
still on the deck
and
I was like I'm going to go in there you
know I I feel in this scenario you know
you owe it to me well it's not that I
owe it to you oh you do is that you know
when your friend's doing something and
trying something and you you kind of
know that like well I know what the
supportive thing to do not that I didn't
want to dance but it's just like I know
that people are not necessarily going to
be into this idea and so I know that
Ward is I basically like I saw myself as
a agent of Dance
do you know what I mean yeah and so I'm
like I'm obviously gonna dance and so
maybe if I'm out there Jesse loves to
dance
and knew she was going to be out there I
knew Christy was going to be dancing so
when you did that I was like all right
let's go and and that that
it got everybody to stop their
conversation because it's like what is
being said it's like this low distorted
voice saying elk count snuggle baby and
it's not stopping
I think I'm on to something there
for this type of thing because it did
work I mean I could have a new one that
just says something like
it's time get your ass on the floor get
your ass but it did work it did work it
did work and you got to say her name you
know in case anybody's wondering right
did you give out any cards
uh let me come back to that okay so I'm
dancing and I'm having a really good
time oh and there was a moment
in which
it actually said this to my wife as I
was dancing because
you did a really smart thing which is
you went into this old school
I mean a lot of it was old school but
you kind of went into this old school
section where it was like you were
playing songs that most of these people
dance to when they were in middle school
high school college-ish right and right
I remember and I told Jesse I was like
this is like when we were kids in the
80s in a song from the 50s would come on
and our parents would start dancing yeah
like that we're all in our 40s we are
doing exactly what they did we're
listening to music from the 80s yeah and
from the 90s
and we're dancing and we and the funny
thing is is Ward's kids were there and
they and and you know they weren't
making they weren't making fun of us
they were joining in and they were
dancing as well but I was like this
isn't necessarily a cool group of people
no we're not but this is a
very happy group of people right now
yeah and everybody's like oh yes like
when you would I don't even really
remember yeah I mean I'm sure you do
remember it because you curated the
playlist but name some of the things
that you were playing
um
you know and I actually did this at
mythicon too so that I pulled out I'm
developing like a bag of tricks and I
have this uh uh
Journey
uh what's the when the lights got down
in the city well I have a I have a
secondary thought about that and other
songs like it which I thought was really
really genius yeah that goes into uh
Billy Joel
um
for the longest time and it's like sing
alongie
and I knew it would get the
40-somethings But the thing that you did
and I made a transition and again I may
be just a guy who just doesn't go to a
lot of dance parties in fact I'm willing
to say uh I am not a guy who goes to a
lot of dance parties but the thing that
you did that I was like
well this is well I don't know why this
doesn't happen more often what
the slow dance section right Ward and I
talk you know what Ward made a joke the
day before we were like do setting
everything up and he was just like you
know at a certain point you need to play
some some Peter Cetera and I was like
that's a good idea we should have a
couple skate that's what I call it well
it's a slow dance section oh and it was
it was several songs and that is what I
call the snuggle baby set and that's why
I have the I have the button I can press
that says
Elkhound doing business is snuggle baby
matter of fact the the signature voice
of that sound bite is here today yeah
Jenna can you demonstrate
oh uh L count snuggle baby
no who's which what do you want me to
say the DBA doing businesses oh uh wow
doing businesses snuggle baby that was
so long ago I know you she did it just
did it I've heard it a million times
Elkhound doing business as snuggle baby
yes and then and then we also have the
modes
remember no well you don't have to get
it that was so long ago this one she's
the voice of the orb from Independence
Day two right I don't remember those
lines either okay no cow mode snuggle
baby mode so I thought that this was
genius and I was like uh this is really
facilitating something and again there
were lots of couples maybe I'm out of
the loop but
I don't remember the last time outside
of a wedding
that that whether it was the stated
purpose of this birthday party was just
to have
a dance party and of course it went into
the slow dancing thing and like my wife
and I just had a wonderful time it was
great we just we danced throughout the
whole thing and I would get this song
going and then I would come out and me
and Christy would dance and then she
would dance with you and Jesse when I
had to go back down yeah so it was tough
when she had to take it for the team
when you've got the DJ's wife out there
on the Dance Floor
um yeah there's a lot of me and Jesse
and Christy dancing together including a
slow dance which was interesting uh but
I felt like cute you know I I'm I you
know I'm again I'm an agent of Dance
and so I I'm here to do whatever I need
to do and
I was thinking this is going really well
we should do this more often
for real yeah yeah I think now you don't
want to do it too often yeah too often
I'm looking at you don't want anybody to
get tired of it
and so the only if I I have one very
very small critique Glory of Love is the
Peterson one very very small critique I
need it I'm ready for it I'm open to it
um Take My Breath Away there was Berlin
there was just a moment where and again
this was you know most people it was a
pretty familiar company and there were
there was only a few couples out on the
dance floor at this time but someone
maybe your wife said something to you
and you just turn the music completely
off and said what uh
about me yeah that was the only
point I was like you should yeah I think
you got to let the song play out and
then you log that and discuss it on the
way home yeah but I don't think the DJ
needing to hear something
justifies cutting the music out and
saying what and listen if someone's
looking for everyone else the music just
stops if someone's going to give a
Careless Whisper George Michael then I'm
gonna stop the music
because I just can't let it burn Usher
it's pretty impressive I just think next
time you say what because it'll be on
beat because if it keeps up I might have
to get on my pony genuine and get the
hell out of here like maybe if it's like
a Lil Jon what timed
what
oh I'll put that on the button too my
technique is maybe maybe you do that
now what about cards my technique is
what about future but my playlist game
is strong and that's what matters the
most and that's what I kept telling
myself I would say it's the and if this
is your target audience yeah it is it is
45 year old people and then occasional
mythical beasts
uh I think and 99 of it is just the
music choices and there was a couple of
places
where the transitions really really
worked
I don't remember what they were yeah but
I just remember thinking like Oh I like
that going into this yeah one thing that
I learned pretty early on is that in it
was this most supportive environment
but if you're playing a song and then
the song ends and people start clapping
because the environment is so supportive
then you've done a bad thing it's like
you should never did that happen yeah
that happened like in the first 40
minutes I kind of I didn't have my my
ducks in a row there was a gap it was a
bit of a gap I haven't been outside at
that point but people people clapped
because they liked the song that it
ended but it's like that's you know you
want to you want to disappear to the
background cut that out I was actually
talking about it afterward in therapy as
kind of a personal Victory because it
wasn't an ultra failure like technically
or otherwise and I was trying to figure
out why as my therapist said sometimes
I'll be talking and it'll be like
when you talk about someone's when you
talk about DJing you light up
and it's like you know it's nice to have
somebody who can say hey this is this is
engaging for you this is this is a this
is tapping into your passion and trying
to figure out
why and some of it is
there's so much psychology there is
elements of being the one in control
you know um
and you know I I kind of enjoy that oh
really yeah and of course I just I just
love music and the amount of uh the
amount of homework that goes into being
able to pull together enough stuff so
that you can make decisions on the fly
like I had I probably had like 12 hours
of Music prepared just so you can just
in case we got holed up well because you
have it in no yeah that's true but just
to go in different directions and say
what what do we need at this moment and
you know oh this isn't working now I
gotta I gotta shift gears kind of thing
that's that challenge is very
fascinating to me and the work that goes
into it is not really work when you find
yourself doing something
that you would do anyway and you can
kind of harness it for something
you know it's uh just listen to music is
is kind of you know is is my hobby so
but back to the control thing
was it before after you know when we had
like our little we went away with some
couples and a lot of times
I'm I like being the person that plays
the music you know right I like to set a
Vibe and I like like oh we're playing
Farkle
what's the right type of music for
farkle we're having a deep conversation
what's the right type of music we're
we're out by the fire and uh people are
laughing and now some somebody seems
like they kind of want to cry what's the
right type of music and
I'm actually I had to learn I really
committed myself to
analyzing this to the point where a
couple of things that I learned was
first of all
sometimes you don't need music
sometimes you gotta know when it's time
to just turn the music off because I
always think that there's the right type
of music for everything
so that's that's the first thing that I
learned from our from our uh
couples weekend away right I put I I can
play music all the time and that's my
instinct but like that's not what
everybody wants and it's trying to like
figure that out be of service and not
just be in control but then there's also
you know Jesse and I have this thing
where it's like we've started to connect
over a few of Victoria Monet that's a
that's our girl we started talking about
her and and uh uh her song on your mama
and like so oh there's this
there's a kindling of something here
that I'm uh I per well here's the first
thing that happened
at a certain point in the evening Jesse
leans over and she's like I've been I've
been controlling the music for hours
she's like can I you mind if I play some
music
and I'm like does that threaten you
it could have gone a number of ways but
I'm like you know what yes you go girl
it's your turn yes
and then I let I let go over the Reigns
and I let her take the music over and
like I didn't even judge it
and I ended up telling her later I was
like you know and it was at Ward's part
we were dancing at Ward's party
because our retreat thing was before it
so because I had put Victoria Monet in
the playlist and it was a point where
there was a law and weren't as many
people on the dance floor and we were
both out on the deck talking and we
heard that song come on and we like
looked at each other and Jesse and I had
this moment and then I was like and we
both got up and we ran in there so we
could dance to our song Me and your wife
have a song I didn't know about this uh
yeah right now yeah we have a song maybe
we should have that fight after all
and so we're dancing I was like you know
what I I want to tell you that I really
appreciate the fact that you asked take
the the rains and and play music the
other weekend
and uh she was like really and I was
like yeah and
um maybe maybe you can have a dual you
can you can maybe my wife's gotta become
a DJ what this is what I said I said
well first of all she said you know it
was actually kind of hard and I was like
I know right but you and you had to
figure it out like the first few songs
listen I I really appreciate the fact
that this is how you approach things
because you know how much I love music
but I do not like
I do not like curating I do not like you
don't want the ox is what the kids say
no no no don't give me the ox I mean
music is my is like my first love but
curating
right it's a different it's a specific
thing I just don't I don't have the
patience for it right it takes more than
just loving music it's other things
um yeah and so she I I enjoy the fact
that she said that it was difficult and
she had to adjust and figure it out and
I was like and you know what I
appreciated the fact that I could devote
my full attention to Farkle in that
moment instead of like dividing my
attention and I could be more engaged in
the conversation instead of kind of
taking a step back and like being on my
phone even though I'm just cueing up
music and then I was like you know what
I think
I think you're ready
I think you're ready for me to take you
under the snuggle baby wing
oh there's a franchise
yes
I'm franchise your wife is joining my
franchise well what's her cut she's
coming under my wing I'm not I don't get
paid anything I know but lady DJs
really really cool I'm just saying well
I'll give her a cut if she starts making
the money you're way better than dude
thanks I'm gonna start wearing a hat and
like big boots with like fish in the
heels and I'm gonna bring her in and
she's gonna spin the
okay I'm gonna be standing back there I
feel like this is like a family
conversation and
that probably needs to happen you know I
think I feel like
I feel like I got to be a part of this
just I just gotta insert my opinion some
what what what what what you you got
nothing to do with this no I think the
question is when is your name I'm her
manager when is your next thing because
uh she's opening for me it's no she's my
Apprentice right okay she's under my
wing she's the wind
um okay I'm looking forward to that it's
not a wing it's an antler she's under my
antler but when is the next gig how do
these gigs happen I don't know you know
it's uh and like I maybe maybe a better
question is is Laura's party still
happening because
Jenna Laura asked me to DJ her party yes
she did and I immediately said yes and
that was like months ago and it was
supposed to be right after Thanksgiving
and then I've heard that it's not
happening well because you know the the
strikes have been happening and Laura
hasn't been working so the uh party well
she's not paying me though well she's
also not paying for a party okay it's a
whole thing so I gotta pay for a party
just so I can have it yeah if you want
to pay for her graduation party okay
yeah okay
I bet you my apprentices will be willing
to chip in okay yeah well as you were
okay so if you're my wife's manager I
feel like maybe I'm I'm
I'm both of y'all's manager just because
I feel like I I feel like
you got to be
you had you gotta think about these next
first of all your willingness I don't
know what the venue would be a club
like I think that like if you want to
make more of this happen I think that's
the most important part no weddings
right right no clubs I'm just not ready
for that and that's a totally different
thing yeah so I don't know what the but
like barbecues
yeah yeah well I think there's you've
kind of got these fires you've got two
opportunities you've got parties like
the one that we had right mixers
and I will say I'll throw this out there
middle-aged mixers Jesse and I have been
talking uh you know we've been talking
about this for a long time
um you know we had the game night thing
baby showers at our house are these
things that you don't want to do because
I don't know yeah yeah well I'm trying
to help you here so here you go
you Jesse and I had the game night thing
for a while then covet hit and
you just it just threw us off not that
we couldn't get back together over the
past couple years but we just haven't
and then we've been talking about what
it looks like to reinstitute something
this fall very busy for Jesse and for me
and we're just like well let's think
about maybe we're talking like 2024 but
you know I told you I think we talked
about it on the podcast a while ago
about
these like themed parties because we
heard about that one that was like
pasta and powerpointers yeah yeah but it
was like everybody has to do this
PowerPoint presentation and then you
have to get somebody else's and then you
have to do it on the spot but then
you're also all making pasta or whatever
we just I'm really I because I the thing
that I the thing I do love to curate is
a full experience like that's something
I have
a passion for thematically I'm not great
at these are the specific things that
need to happen in the specific order
because the details sort of like is
where I lose interest but like ideas
broad ideas the theme like this meets
this let's get this person to do this
and this person to do this and let's
invite these people like I've really
been thinking hard about this
about beginning to
do these kinds of things probably at our
house you talking about a soiree uh
Soiree might be too Soiree sounds like
somebody's getting naked okay I don't
think anybody's getting naked unless
that's like part of the performance a
special evening with yeah but it would
be like oh there's this person that can
play this very specific instrument in
this very fascinating way and they're
and they're like really really well
known if you know about this instrument
and we're gonna have okay so we're gonna
have somebody come and we're gonna all
make this meal together and then this
person is going to bring out this
instrument and they're going and they're
gonna play it okay things like that
I've been and I'm trying to think of
ways to put together the themes right
but I definitely feel like
if we begin doing that I there's
definitely especially if it's not a
musical performance kind of night I feel
like this is a perfect opportunity for
Elkhound snuggle baby too that would be
a great venue to be like we're going to
dance like tonight we're going to dance
oh dance okay you know or we just need
some we just need some music for the
event curated by Elkhound snuggle baby
he's not really like at a booth tonight
but just so you know like there could be
like little signs there's just like
questions about the playlist ask elk
count snuggle baby you know just I don't
know we got to come up with different
systems because it's you're kind of like
but the thing that I need is I need an
occasion to use the DJ deck oh you all
and that will be provided as well well
then I have to and I have to man The
Deck that's how it works
I'm just saying that there could be a
convergence here because I'm thinking
about it yeah like curated events that
then could require DJing I'm here for
you I'm here for you but you got to be
very affordable for the time being you
got to think about it you got to think
about because again yeah we had you got
to get to it there's going to be a time
where
you do need to put feedback on my face
that that's what I thought you were
going to get to like because you gave me
that it was dark I don't know posture
movements
anything like that
um I can't say all right I was that I
thought about it good I wasn't looking
at you a whole lot at one point you came
over to me and you wanted to have a very
detailed conversation about this podcast
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep yeah because I mean hit me in the
moment and it was I went in early on a
song right and I was about to leave
yeah and I had a thought yeah and uh I'm
glad I had that conversation because I
was like if I don't have this
conversation with linked right now I
might forget why would you do that this
moment of inspiration and so uh we had
that and I think it I I I think I'm glad
we had that conversation yeah me too
um but I couldn't give you my full
attention because I wasn't no so no
notes on your uh facial expression
performance or anything but ultimately
what I'm getting at is there will come a
time for you to Dawn the horns I think I
want antlers I want to set up the thing
where it becomes my backdrop and then I
can back up into it like like an avatar
you know like like well in the movie
Avatar where they like get in the
machine and then all of a sudden oh and
they attach yeah like I I wanna I wanna
add a little stand to my thing so it
becomes my backdrop and then I can like
back up it and then all of a sudden I'm
gonna have to start charging if they're
gonna do that kind of thing yeah that
sounds expensive that sounds like new
pneumatics
hydraulics
I I think it might just be a couple of
straps
no but I I think it it made that was
like I don't know net ward has a
decision to make is it are we going back
to us singing sing-along are we gonna do
dance party it's it's a legitimate
question
can you do both
I don't know maybe you can
you've got the system there
but they they do feel like sort of
distinctly different right right paths I
need a couple of different venues
so I can get better well thanks for the
feedback I'm glad we got to talk about
that because yeah I want to keep the
momentum going and there is something
about like you get lulled into a place
where it's like oh you know
I got to develop my skill on the Wheels
of Steel right I mean the one thing to
remember I think is next time before you
announce that it's about time to dance
look at the door that you're about to go
through before you say anything
memorize how it works where the opening
is I will embarrass myself then turn
around say now people might be like that
might become your thing this guy's going
like just you got to see this guy he's
gonna do something right at the
beginning you never know what it's going
to be there is going to be an implosion
yeah yeah but it's all but it's all part
of it I've Gotten Good at it I think I'm
really good at just moving on from it
like I've had enough like unmitigated
embarrassing moments you'll be in
trouble if you just you let it slow you
down she's like just to just get up and
keep going man
uh no but you recovered well
it was a very memorable party it's my
wreck I'm gonna I'm gonna wreck uh
Victoria Monet her her new album I think
it's called Jaguar two it's a sequel
it features uh me and Jesse's Song
on my mama hold on is it I feel like
this is a little awkward because isn't
that all my mama that's like a sex song
that my wife and I make love to
isn't it
was for you to ask her man no it's not I
mean Jesse she
yeah yeah yeah yeah she she curated
hour I curated one playlist and then she
was like and then it got kind of old and
then she took over and I was very happy
about that oh I did that for her
no I didn't all right that's my wreck
oh this has been a fun one I'm a little
sweaty hashtag year biscuits let us know
what you think or leave us a voicemail
1-88
earpod one you know what play some
voicemails now hi guys my name is sunny
and I have officially caught up on ear
biscuits I started listening to it a
couple months ago doing ubereats and now
I kind of don't know what to do with my
life because I'm caught up on every
single one of y'all's podcasts and yeah
just thank you for keeping me sane while
I was on the road even though I would
sometimes have dreams that we were all
friends because I listened to you guys
so much so
yeah anyway thank you bye to watch more
ear biscuits click on the playlist on
the right to watch the previous episode
of your biscuits click on the playlist
to the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
foreign
[Music]